planning on being outdoors this summer
lifestyle expert don mccarthy is sharing
some great products that can help you
enjoy the experience
hi las vegas it's time for some fun and
healthy ways to enjoy the great outdoors
like i am
first up if you have kids this is a
must-have from the california beach
co it's the world's lightest
parent-tested and approved
uv protected play pen for kids called
the pop and go
this ultimate portable kid play yard is
built to last for years simple to
transport and has a pop and release
technology
for easy setup and take down the pop and
go weighs just 7.2 pounds
no weight limit inside either parent so
you can squeeze in there with your kids
and it comes with a carrying bag for
extra convenience and comfort
having a safe functional space for your
kids to play in
within seconds indoors or whether you're
outdoors is
genius go to thecaliforniabeachco.com to
get yours today
now it's time for some yummy goodness
from snack brand go go squeeze
introducing their brand new almond blend
pudding pouches
these pouches are a must for outdoor
adventures
especially hiking through parks where
you kind of need a healthy snack
that is free go go squeeze is also
helping to get more kids no matter where
they live into the great outdoors this
summer
by partnering with the national park
foundation to fund field trips for kids
to learn
outdoors and just have some fun there
are a ton of flavor options with these
plant-based puddings
for a sweet fix flavors like banana
vanilla chocolate and cocoa hazelnut
these new go go squeeze almond blend
puddings contain 30 percent less sugar
compared to traditional dairy pudding
and there's no need for them to be
refrigerated so it's a perfect snack for
a day in the park
making some s'mores like i did for a
treat at night or long road trip
go to gogosqueeze.com for more
information or pick them up pretty much
everywhere nationwide next if you're
like me
you don't like pesky bugs or mosquitoes
when you are outside
paraquito to the rescue with fun and
easy to wear wristbands for adults and
kids
clips sprays roll-on gel and sandals yes
sandals
periquito just partnered with cool shoe
to develop this unique
and innovative first ever made mosquito
repellent sandals
thanks to its defu control technology
these sandals are comfortable
water resistant and help you make the
most out of your summer and just being
outdoors while still being protected
against mosquito bites
parakito products are all natural deet
free skin friendly
and can be found in health food stores
pharmacies outdoor retailers
and are available in more than 40
countries worldwide
go to parakito.com today trust me you'll
thank me later
lastly let's get outside with the kids
and enjoy a ride
razor is a brand that embodies the
spirit of fun and freedom since it was
founded over 20 years ago
their new flashback scooter for kids is
retro inspired available in bright pink
or blue
with air tires and hand brakes making it
the ride kids will be crazy about
this scooter has a weight capacity of
220 pounds and best for ages 8 and up
for the adults my go-to is the e prime 3
electric scooter
which has impressive features like an
led headlight brake
activated tail light it reaches up to 18
miles per hour and travels 15 miles on a
single charge
folds easily affordable and lightweight
razer truly offers something for the
entire family
not to mention a fun way to get around
go to razer.com to get one today
now for more information on any of these
products i featured go to
dawnscorner.com
happy summer i love go go squeeze thanks
don there's more